so recently i went into my doctor's
office and i was told that my blood
pressure was 115 over 75.
so i thought we would talk about exactly
what this means and try to figure out
how to how to think about blood pressure
in general using these numbers and this
experience
as kind of a launching point
so
the way i think about blood pressure is
i always imagine kind of a
tube
and i imagine blood going through that
tube and this tube is like a blood
vessel so there's blood trying to get
its way from one side to the other
and
on its way the the kind of neat thing
that it's doing
is
as it flows it's pushing out so it's
forcing
against these walls
and uh specifically what i mean by that
you know there's cells and there's
plasma
and all that stuff is pushing out
against the walls of the blood vessels
so you've got a force
and that force is being exerted on the
surface area of the blood vessel so it's
force over a surface area
and
anytime you see force over an area you
know that equals pressure and in this
case it's a blood pressure because it's
the blood that's doing
that work
so
this is how i think of blood pressure
specifically is those little blue arrows
and
the two questions that kind of pop into
my mind anytime i'm thinking about uh
blood pressure are
where
is the blood pressure being taken and
when are you taking it so let's start
with the first question where and
by that i mean where in the circulatory
system so you've got the heart
and it's my valentine's day heart
and you've got
the aorta coming off of the heart and
it's got lots of branches but i'm to
just draw
one branch which is the artery
leading off to my arms this is called
the brachial artery
going off to my arm
and usually
i'd say 90 percent of the time maybe
even more the blood pressure that you're
getting recorded or the number that's
being told to you is being checked at
this point
i marked it with a little x because
that's kind of the upper arm right so
that's usually where they're checking
the blood pressure and again they're
checking the force that the blood is
putting on the vessel wall so these
little blue arrows
so that answer is the where question and
certainly you can imagine if i check
blood pressure let's say at some other
spot you know let's say
over here or over here you know you
might get a different blood pressure
reading than if i check the yellow x so
really we're just talking about that one
spot
now the other question is you know when
are you checking it so
for this let me show you a little
table or a figure rather so imagine that
over time
time is this way
you have different recordings for blood
pressure so this will be blood pressure
and blood pressure is usually measured
in millimeters of mercury so i'll write
millimeters of mercury here
and let's go from 200 all the way down
to zero
and
i'll use my numbers that i got from the
doctor the other day uh to illustrate
what i'm trying to say so
right at that x that yellow x
at the bottom let's say uh of my reading
i've got 75 so let's start at 75 which
is about here
as the heart is pumping
the pressure starts building up and it
gets up to about 115.
so really what is happening is blood is
making its way from the heart as it
squeezes
towards that ax
and as it gets there
the force
that it's putting on the walls is going
up up up and as it goes up it goes from
75 all the way to 115
so that all happens during the squeezing
part
of the heart cycle and we call that
systole
so this is all happening during systole
which is when the heart is squeezing
down and we know the heart is a pump
now from that point forward the heart
begins to relax
so at this point at 1 15 the heart is
now relaxing slowly and as it relaxes
the pressure begins to fall
and it continues to fall all the way out
here and
the pressure gets down to about 75 again
and this is diastole so this is when the
heart is actually
taking a break from squeezing and is now
refilling
and we call that gasoline so i'll call
that refilling
and so during systole you spend about a
third of the time
and in diastasis you spend about
two-thirds of the time
and i'm talking about one heartbeat here
so this would be one heartbeat
so it's not 50-50
and the easy way to remember this is in
a given day 24-hour day i spent about
eight hours working and about 16 hours
relaxing or or not working and so i
think of the heart doing it squeezing
its work
for uh eight out of 24 would be about a
third kind of the same as me about a
third of the time the heart is relaxing
or i'm sorry squeezing
so that's how the heart is spending its
time
in systole and diastole and the pressure
is ranging between 115 and 75. so really
it's never just 115 or just 75. it's
somewhere between the two and you know
for example if i checked right here in
time you know it might be let's say 85
or here it might be 102 or here it might
be you know let's say 87. so it's
somewhere between 15 and 115 and 75.
so this number then this number i wrote
up here becomes a range this is the
range
of blood pressure
so when i talk about when it really
depends on when in the cycle you're at
and you're somewhere in that range and
when i talk about the where we know that
we're talking about a reading that's
taken in the upper arm so those are the
two thoughts that should cross your mind
every time you hear a blood pressure
recording and of course the top number
115 again is the systolic blood pressure
and 75 is the diastolic blood pressure